well I'd like to welcome you all here
this afternoon my name is Peter on i'm
professor of islam in the religion
department I'm director of the Middle
East Institute and I'm Dean of one of
the undergraduate colleges the school of
general studies and I have the privilege
of introducing our panelists today the
moderator for the evening is a wonderful
close friend and I'm delighted that we
had an excuse to get her back to the
campus dr. Lisa Anderson is currently
the Provost of the American University
in Cairo apost she's held since 2008 but
she still remains the James T shock well
professor of international relations
here at Columbia and is in fact the
former dean of the School of
International Affairs in which this
event is taking place prior to being
Dean she was chair of the Department of
Political Science served as director of
the Middle East Institute and before
joining Columbia she was an assistant
professor at Harvard Lisa Anderson is
the author of a number of books her most
recent pursuing truth exercising power
social science and public policy in the
21st century which received absolutely
superb reviews and Lisa and I have known
each other for more years than either of
us will admit exactly and we began a
relationship in the worst arabic class
ever given on the planet at a harvard
university but it was so memorable that
we've never forgotten each other good
our panelists are a distinguished group
with varied backgrounds that will
contribute really I think
enormously to the discussion hisham
methought was born here in New York City
but his family moved when he was a young
child first to Tripoli in Libya and then
to Cairo he eventually went to boarding
school in the UK and has remained in
London ever since his first novel in the
country of men was published in 2006 was
shortlisted for the man booker prize The
Guardian first book award and the
national book critics circle award in
the u.s. it 16 international literary
awards including the commonwealth
writers prize best first book award for
europe and south asia the royal society
society live literature on da che prize
and the inaugural arab-american book
award it's been translated into 28
languages mansour ecclesia is chair of
the department of political science and
geography at the University of Texas San
Antonio dr. Alicia is also a columnist
and is the author of Libya's qaddafi the
politics of contradiction his published
works on Libyan politics in human rights
in the Middle East are extraordinarily
broadly red and very influential he's
testified before the US Congress
European Parliament specialized United
Nations committees as well as American
Canadian and European government agency
last but not least is holly acme de who
is chair of political science and look
teacher of liberal arts and science at
the university of new england his
specialty is political theory
comparative politics and historical
sociology his scholarship focuses on
power agency and anti-colonial
resistance in North Africa especially in
modern Libya he is the author of the
make
king of modern Libya stake formation
colonization and resistance forgotten
voices power and agency and colonial and
postcolonial Libya and post Orientalism
critical reviews in North African social
and cultural history and finally I want
to thank really very seriously the young
man whose brainchild this was and who
put it together single-handedly in
absolutely meticulous fashion use of
Assad is a senior at Columbia and i'm
proud to say at the school of general
studies the college that i run he is a
major in the newly named department as i
get it right or if I get it wrong
correct me Middle East South Asian and
African Studies just to be as Middle
East in there and we hope you will be
graduating this may if not soon after
and really we owe him a great debt this
is a wonderful topic we in a sense do
not do enough nah on Libya and it's
placed within the Arab world and more
broadly especially as it goes through a
renascence so let me introduce you say a
couple of words and we will begin
thank you doctor on and good afternoon I
would like to thank you all for joining
us today I would also like to thank the
Middle East Institute the department of
Middle East South Asian and African
Studies the Institute of African Studies
and four for their sponsorship of this
event many people have been instrumental
in making this possible I would briefly
like to thank professors Peter on rashid
khalidi shareable magni- doof and
sudipta cobb garage and from the Middle
East Institute i would like to thank
Astrid Benedict and Merlin Paul Jay jute
of course none of this would have been
possible without our moderator lisa
anderson who was willing to meet with a
curious undergraduate and point them in
the direction of libyan studies so thank
you dr. Anderson most of all I would
like to thank our panelists for their
patients in coordinating this event
through their writing they breathe life
into the discourse of modern Libya as a
modern state Libya has been described as
a rogue state a failed state a rentier
state a state sponsor of terror a
kingdom and the state of the masses the
list of course continues Libya's
experience with modernity like many
other post-colonial nations has been
characterized by a series of
socio-political shocks Italian
colonization alone decimated the
population to such a degree that the
population remained largely unchanged
between 1911 and 1950 the discovery of
significant oil reserves in the 1950s
catapulted a nation from being an
exporter of scrap metal left over from
World War two to being the largest to
being one of the largest exporters of
petroleum in the world today Libya has
the largest proven oil reserves in the
entire African continent and is ranked
ninth overall and it's proven oil
reserves in the world despite its vast
endowment of resources Libya's social
political and economic development have
often at all
and taken a backseat to other more
complex challenges as an American
student of Libyan descent much of my
academic experience has been concerned
with the formation of the Libyan state
its history its culture although there
is a great deal that has been written in
the field of Arab and Islamic studies a
field that has grown exponentially in
the last ten years it can be difficult
to hone in on the topic of Libya much of
the pre state literature about Libya's
borna the orientalist Canon social
anthropologists serving as military or
political officers attempted to decipher
segments of Libya's resistance again
against italian occupation through a
tribal structure they simultaneously
argued against the horrors of Italian
colonization while searching for their
own clients to install scholarship of
the state era during the period of
Libya's constitutional monarchy has yet
to receive much attention after 1969 as
the nation took a larger role in the
world stage scholarship has lived on
Libya has dipped it drifted towards a
focus mostly on Libya's foreign policy
one can search the internet and read the
Atlantic Council's policy
recommendations regarding the next steps
for the United States and Libya while
such recommendations are vital in
fostering deep and productive interstate
relations policy recommendations due to
institutional constraints can generalize
theories that lack a fully contextual
perspective
in organizing this panel I realized that
a crucial perspective was omitted from
the Bali body of work devoted on Libya
it becomes the contextual perspective
oblivion intellectuals I have found
knowledge gaps that as a student I was
unable to account for in the chasm
between policy driven scholarship
orientalist and Poe story Angeles
perspectives a sense of what Libya was
and is for Libyans themselves has yet to
be fully articulated I believe we must
take a closer look at the sociological
determinants of the major political and
economic shifts in Libya's history our
natural resources India curse and if so
how insurmountable are they as obstacles
to stable development as we begin our
discussion we ask you to consider what
is omitted from the field of scholarship
on Libya and what Libyans think one way
of gauging that is accessing a range of
Libyan intellectual opinion and analysis
this panel embodies the spirit the
approaches of our panelists are as
diverse as they are committed to making
sense of Libya today we hope that this
discussion may rise opportunities for
the critical production of knowledge
required in the burgeoning study of
Libya thank you and welcome
to our moderator dr. Anderson to get us
started thank you very much and I want
to echo Peter ons thanks to you Yusuf
for having put this together for me this
is an exceptional treat an opportunity
to see some old friends and and as you
will shortly here a new friend as well i
hope the 20th century was exceptionally
cruel to libya and I think music is not
wrong to suggest that this is something
that was true in some other parts of the
world the experience of European
imperialism was difficult for many
countries but i think the entire 20th
century was as I said unusually cruel
and difficult for Libya and I think a
lot of what we struggle with now in both
trying to think about Libya's future and
in fact even finding the Libyan
intellectuals to whom Yusuf referred can
be attributed to the difficulties that
the country faced over the course of
that century and I say that thinking in
fact that the 19th century was an
interesting and and actually engaging
century in Libya with a lot of
interesting development and potential so
it's all the more difficult to look at
that of the last century given how much
potential there was at the beginning so
i hope we spent some time thinking about
what the 21st century made promise
perhaps we really are at the beginning
of turning around a history that is has
been unfair to nearly everyone who has
lived in the country i'm delighted to be
able to in a sense indulge in this
conversation tonight and it will be a
conversation we will have three
presentations from each of the panelists
and then
a fairly relaxed discussion among them
and with you about the their sense of
the challenges and prospects for the
country two of them alien monster I have
known for a very long time we have been
in the trenches and trying to understand
would be it for a long time and it's
been a joy and I commend their work to
all of you his shan by contrast is a new
acquaintance i bred in the country of
men twice and I have to compliment you
not only on the book itself but on which
I also commend to all of you but it's
it's takes place at precisely the time
that I was doing my wrists first
research in Libya in the late 1970s and
it takes place in precisely the
neighborhood of Tripoli where I was
living and I promise you this is exactly
what it was like so I really it's just
an amazing book so if I'm not going to I
don't want to say if you only read one
thing about Libya it should be hit shams
book but because i have two people who
have written wonderful things about
libya but any of this you will profit
from and enjoy on that note I think I
want to turn the microphone over to Ali
first and we'll just go down the the
panel and then we will start a
conversation thanks very much
okay thank you
that's good enough or you lose I guess
the shift
I think
hot Erica that we break the woman soon
ok
I would like to thank you sir for his
energy and his determination to put this
panel together I would like also to
thank the Middle East Institute it's a
pleasure to be here in the big city
coming from the countryside in Maine and
seeing the wonderful new york city and
also good to see visa and i get to know
each amp and see a monsewer as well it's
a pleasure to be here with you this is
maybe my third time here at Columbia I
what I would like to share with you is
something related to my research and
especially the project that they have
been involved in the last ten years and
it has to do with a missing link despite
Lisa's pioneering work and other
people's work earlier which is how the
burden of history or the bloody and
brutal 20th century has been ignored and
there is so much silence about it to the
point that is shocking especially in a
scholarly community so I hope to share
with you at a presentation and forgive
me for bringing some pictures on some of
them are very gruesome because that
probably will bring us to see the larger
context of contemporary politics I
haven't written much about contemporary
politics I started my work on the
colonial period due to family and
personal influences on me as a young
child and I got stuck with the colonial
period until now the good side about
that is it has been good to me because I
I cannot even my understanding and I
became an area that's flourishing and
once again thanks to Lisa's pioneering
work that started a very sophisticated
work on Libya and Tunisia but looks like
Tunisia was regarding and most of the
interest on Lisa's work has been Olivia
anyway what I would like to share with
you something related to my work on
Libya's Canadian history and in the
process i would like to see if i can
present to you why the burden of history
is important to all of us and understand
contemporary Libya that the president is
really is the is related to the past and
the past is really the history of the
present and the but I would like to
focus on is how Libya's colonial past
has been viewed and once through the
struggle political and scholarly own
understanding that passed in 2005 I
published a book and I called it
forgotten voices and the reason for that
this is a young woman a worker in city
of tripoli in 1960 and a tobacco a
factor in and Tripoli first generation
and her family and you could see that
she still wears the Libyan traditional
dress and looks in a complex way I love
that look and I decided that would be
the cover of it why I called the book
for getting voices because the fact that
there is a silence I thought about a
certain aspect of liquids colonial
history when it comes to Italian
colonization and especially the fascist
colonization of Libya
now
let me share with you a little bit of
some quotes to drive the point to to
explain what do I mean by silence the
image of italian fascism when compared
with the german Nazism is always being
looked in a different way there is the
nasty case and there is really the
lesser evil or the benign one and if you
I looked at the literature after that
and began to understand that with the
few exceptions the story has been really
presented or absent from scholarship for
example mr. Berlusconi refer to the
fascist dictatorship in such a way my
great and beloved Hannah Arendt who Maya
liked and admired to this day she said
that the fascist dictatorship in Italy
was really just dictatorship thought
about me to do with much of of the
nastiness of the Nazi despite the fact
she was pioneering in her scholarship
about the connection between the
European colonization especially in the
Congo and the Holocaust and the
genocidal estate in Germany later on I
think the only way I could explain her
because i am very by sir she didn't know
much about libyan case and I think she
even though she tackled theoretically
sophisticated way a lot of these aspects
she thought that was just the dictator
now I found some letters that I guess
indicate that the intention is not just
an accident of War general adelio
rotational granny in 1930 that's really
if it takes to terminate the whole
population of silly nayuka be it this is
the voice of progress and we have to do
it and then of course we allow the the
native people to tell us about how they
experience alone ization they tell us a
different story and the Jewish Italian
journalist Eric Salerno and his final
book about genocide in Libya he
interviewed some some of the survivors
and the story is one of them the intern
people he said we had come to 50 but
dead bodies were taken from the
concentration camps for bed every day
now questions to guide us so will not be
open-ended and I think it might be a
good idea to keep that in mind is what
does the dominant image of the
colonization Italian fashion
specifically as a benign speed and
persist in the media why'd you know
persist in the media and a scholarly
studies and what are some of the moral
and the scullery flaws of this myth of
Italian fascism and how did the
recovered from oral history and other
sources could tell us about that kind of
representation
this is of course to give you an idea
about Libya as you can see it's very
very huge big country in terms of size
the forges largest country and its it
has a very interesting tale of political
opposition in the whole Mediterranean
and Africa and this is of course a
modern map of Libya and they have my
birthday's there what then which I
insists for my students any geography
quiz unless they know that they're going
to flunk the exam so it's there and I'm
delighted this is very important to me
there were 5,000 people when I was born
there so let's not lose sight of that
now some of the argument I think I think
that would be related to this this
question of representation
debunking the the lesser evil model is
very important but also challenging
nationalism I in the last twenty years I
began to challenge not only the colonial
model on knowledge and categories but
also I think nationalism we have to take
it also as critically and this is
something a sort of evaluating my own
upbringing and my own you know ideas
when I was growing up in Libya in in
general and dad you know challenging the
colonial scholarship also requires
challenging the today's national
scholarship as well and the the last
point of my argument about the burden of
history is I think it's no longer
possible for us in the 21st century to a
see things in isolation to think of
europe or italian fascism in isolation
without looking at what happened in the
colonies would be myopic and vice versa
understanding libyan and an Egyptian and
North African and African experience we
were looking at Europe will be also
myopic so the idea of to say scholarship
and isolation area studies to me is
really now I think need to be reexamined
at least without being
about that now colonial scholarship is
verra divided into three sections
colonial scholarship eurocentric
scholarship and national scholarship now
as the going back to a colonial
scholarship is open till nine seventy
Italians colors did not deal with the
with the with the example of the camps
absolutely only in D and after 1970s
some scholars began to deal with that
you know since the eurocentric
scholarship that the idea of proper
gently for example entire Booker has a
wonderful book that I recommend to all
of you where's the idea that you know
this is the Nazi the Sherman who are the
nasty ones Italians are good people nice
people they don't do these things but
also the media and the denial and in
Italy has been really overwhelming I
didn't know that and I think with my
business and my immerse in Italian
scholarship I began to say something has
to be explained why silence wisely and
your symptoms scholarship is related to
what I need said earlier is that the
idea that you look at these colonial
experiences from the lenses and
assumptions and the choices of European
modernizing colonization which I think a
lot of people have challenged that
before the the national scholarship
especially in Libya has really troubled
with that in various ways just to give
you an example that the back of the
still raging today within the state and
also outside the state where everybody
wants to see themselves as the true
representative of the heroes of the
anti-colonial resistance and scholarship
would be published outside Libya I give
you an example one of the leaders of the
durability Nia Republic the son of
identity betrayed published his father's
memoirs in Tunisia austronesian scholar
to write that the
the one of the other leaders of the
italian republic the late shift on Zoey
was an exile in Egypt and also today the
scholarship on contemporary olivia has
to do with appropriating the colonial
period to fit the state a current state
in Libya and it's only as you ever now
the attentive scholarship you have it's
not so bleak there are people who were
aware of the connections that I'm
talking about Antonio Gramsci in his
present notebooks here was about that
post-colonial intellectuals Ave Caesar
frantz fanon Sameer Emile and Columbia's
mijangam Danny wrote about that very
much and the connection between the two
now the late rich anthropologist and
officer IE even Richard wrote about
detailed analysis of the what happened
in the cams and the brutal colonization
in Libya but also a as Lisa once
reviewed the book it was slanted it was
also for other purposes to you know mr.
mais the new regime in Egypt now Lisa in
here you know dissertation and book that
was published it really was aware of the
atrocities and here writing and she has
spoken about that that's most important
and also in her presentation and always
brought the fact that Libyan
colonization Libyans experience with
colonization is not like any others
probably one of the most brutal and
savage experiences that decimated the
population maybe half of it in the first
half of the 20th century and to
understand Libyans they really have to
understand them they might sound very
very crazy erratic emotional that's not
because of biological reasons because
also the the fact that this polarization
was
indeed with the exception of Algeria and
the Congo and maybe her aerial people in
Namibia is one of the most one of the
worst examples now in Italy there some
scholars who really courageously refuse
to a little silence go and i want to
point out to you that the work of
georgia rochette andrew de boca as
journalist by alec salerno my colleague
nicola la banca and also in why you are
a colleague of mine by the name
historian by the nina routine Guyot who
also has been very very courageous in
challenging this image now what I'm
talking about so we would be in the
picture I'm talking about with the
internment of between we know that the
minimum number eighty thousand to some
of us think 120,000 total population of
civilian Salonika and how they were
interred between 1929 1930 3 in these
camps three years through cydia hamedan
maroon labrea and de gala the gala would
be equivalent of the issuance of the
Libyan internment the worst cam of all
and every year in the last 80 years I
have been going to these camps visiting
the cemeteries trying to interview the
survivors and they began after one year
to talk to me so now I call them I
interview them and I go back and
interview more I have only a limited
time before many of them would passed
away but what happened is that the
silence of the archives which is either
destroyed or denied by the Italian
authorities would be a comment
by listening to survivors and I had to
learn all the methods all the techniques
of oral history and especially our rich
nigga and cultural production of sherry
shabby or folk poetry I haven't finished
my work I'm up to 150 interviews so I
hope that and start maybe by by next
year and start writing the finding of
the now also i want to share with you
out of the hundred or 115 or maybe at
least 100,000 people including children
and elderly only half of them came out
and they didn't guess them the italian
did not guess them they starved them and
they do not read them so many of them
died of trust and hunger and diseases in
the most striking the most heartbreaking
scene was going to see the cemeteries
the cemeteries um were just horrific to
me now if we allow the subaltern or
those ordinary people to speak to us and
if we allow them agency then probably
will listen a different narrative that
will not find in the archives
and I think I found some memoirs like by
ibrahim al Marri i found also at the
libyan study center in tripoli gave me
all the collected material around 20
volumes and i had to sit through them to
find the material related by camps and i
discovered that the most important
record is the fault poetry and for
poetry especially that was composed
during internment and some of them are
memorized by Libyans like the one by
piggy deprivation iffy and the mackeir
the void of each cam had number of poets
who wrote a composed poems of Dooley
internment and in a very civilized be
published to collection of poetry that
was crucial but also I found more
recorded ones and this for poetry is
unique cultural production for Libyan
people the people who don't read the
right but they will compose for two and
it's a fascinating record and by the way
there are many female pose and I put I
put some of these poems in my book pro
rata voices and my dear friend Harlem
ozawa translated for a reservation with
his epic poem which I think the most
devastating poem that you read about the
horrors of colonialism and fascism now
this little biography of for a
reservation banoffee the poet who will
outlast fascism because the poem is
almost 20 loan pages and it's going to
be available in my new book in full
English translation so you know English
readers will be available to read his
background I'm trying to find out a
photo or but I have failed for the last
five years I'm very very determined I'm
usually I don't give up sometimes I wait
15 years and I don't know if I'd be
rewarded but I'm still
to find a photo of figure ship now the
oral tradition or the old history tell
us about all these items to portation
daily live food or clothes forced labor
illness trauma and death and I try to
collect as much as I can and the stories
some of them are in my book some are now
I'm adding more material on them these
are pictures of the camps that we found
in the archives I'm going to share with
you they by the way that what they did
they marched thousands of the civilian
population or put them in ships from the
javelin doctor and the other parts of
Sri Lanka or berapa to the desert of
search and there is an aerial picture of
Allah BR can
these are pictures of people who were
hanged a during the you know the
invasion I prominent archives and this
is a picture of a mass grave this is a
horrific picture of one of the massacres
there and you could see people who are
completely naked that 3d reminded me of
a lot of pictures of flow of the German
Nazi there and these are some of the
people i have been seeing and visiting
every year that's another gala camp I'm
it with them there with a friend of mine
dr. Bertel I raheem and they were all in
turn the cam as teen as early teens and
they began to tell us about it this is
one of them this is the son of one of
the commander sub commanders of alma
mater and his name is Mohamed earth Mary
chamois and he has the most remarkable
memory he is almost 80 something and his
memory is you know it will rival any any
young man I still called him every eight
to greet him and I see him at balaji
every year he gave me details and he
opened gave me a surprise he draw a map
out of his imagination of de gala camp
its location
it's you know where they were sit
everything and he drove from his own
imagination and it's a remarkable one
this is in one of my other business to
salute and I met with with some of the
survivors this is one of the survivors
and his son in the background I was
there talking with him and it was fun
interview but he made a lot of made fun
of my hat on my sneakers there and I
deserved that property yes and this is
in livonia also outside Benghazi I went
there there was a warning and they they
said you know we have somebody died but
then he said you know professor he came
all the way from America I can't get you
go without interview so we took a corner
and we we had two hours interview about
his internment his memory of the
internment this is an another village
called la Tanya also in that nice turn
roles in America and we went there and
this is hash abdul majeed ab drogba I
Gabey and he his memory was he was a
very grumpy old man and he kept shouting
at me and but I get what I want from him
that day these are two of my colleagues
for me a very simple nod to history
department professor at the above zoom
and professor of the library he who
facilitated that this visit this is a
remarkable lady she is the daughter I
think a problem Lisa will remember her
name the father at the name of her
father she is the daughter of a great
commander of the our gear Grella door
abdullah dasha is her father push push
otama gusta me gusta because his hair
was very bushy and goes this way she
said that but people made fun of himself
there Colton you know the one with the
hair that stands like
and she to my shock she lived in somehow
where my father and she was in a good
health very very very sharp and she told
me about her father and that was a nice
surprise I also got some of her father's
papers that time now this is the
horrific this is the head of boom Atari
in Cobra where the was the nenes I mean
a good CIA's the troops after they
defeated the resistant they severed his
head these are horrific pictures that's
from colonial Libya I'm sorry to spoil
your afternoon but I want you to see
that so you'll put the idea of benign
colonialism to rest maybe pom and you
will see some of the horrors of that
period this is of course you are aware
that this is the capture of the
legendary leader Amon mutare and the
trial also part of the process to the
trial and the conclusion I let me
conclude since we really have limited
time and I could address some of aspect
of my research about the burden of
history in Libya for the colonial
history if what we have now the colonial
past of Libya is really represented by
conflicting point of views official ones
and scholarly ones we still have the
reproduction of colonial a scholarship
representing the colonial past Libya's
path as hard but also modernizing the
eurocentric point of view that doesn't
see much about that just a phase and the
process of understanding Europe as a
certain boy and national scholarship the
triune the the 40s the during the
solution monarchy laughter 1969 to which
different agendas and different digital
systemizing a view of history and being
aware of who's produces what kind of
knowledge and what kind of
representation will allow us to
understand that that the nature of the
struggle over Libya's colonial past the
I think my own take is really to look at
history from the bottom up to look at
the subaltern look at the ordinary
groups women slaves servants ordinary
people and how they deal with these
process and under pressures in them and
I think we all would benefit from
pressuring the italian state to release
and open the the files on the archives
and this is a crow say that had been
leading for at least 15 years and i have
been kicked out of the italian archives
once but i think i'm going to still be
gonna be a thorn in their underside we
can probably I retire or even after I
retire and I think I'm not longer I
think interested in just a story about
how horrible is colonial burden or
colonial history I think if we want to
go beyond colonialism and nationalism we
want to see also the commonalities not
only the difference is the commonalities
that bridge the divide between people in
Europe and also in northern Africa and
the United States and in that region
that will not happen without debunking
stereotypes and representations that
will not happen without going beyond
leaders and elites
and States and try to reach the
societies and understand their specific
but also discover their commonalities
and by appreciating that Libyan people
when they look created was when they
look at us very angry they are not
really biologically efficient but
actually they very very natural reaction
against what they their grandparents and
what their parents and the suit they
have been told in dealing with the 20th
century and the 21st century I'll start
here and I'm sorry for the too long and
the last thing I would like to say to
you this is there is a biographical up
note this is me in the sixth grade in
seven when I had a more hair than now
and both grandparents were active in the
you know attack lung diseases and
grandmother who had family in turned so
I had also a biographical personal note
that's not to make it personal but I
didn't choose this topic I would have
just scholarly interest it was also to
give them justice and find the truth
about what happened in the 20th century
thank you
we thank you very much i can't tell you
how heartening it is to see the revival
of the kind of scholarly networks that
we hoped would develop decades ago and i
think the kind of work you're doing is
exactly work that probably should have
been done long ago but it's wonderful to
see it happening now this is a story
that needs to be told so thank you again
on toward the floor as you are next yes
I do want you to go next what i will do
i pick up for he left all ok the Italian
experience was not very pleasant the
truth is wasn't because by the time they
left Libya was emerges the poorest
country in the world literacy rate was
close to ninety nine point six percent
infant mortality rate was forty percent
per capita income was less than a
hundred dollars not tell you my own
personal experience in this my first
school was often arabic school because
there were no teachers italians were
interested in teaching Libyans only how
to read an envelope so they can deliver
one place to another no Libyans are
allowed to go beyond the third second
and third grade education so there were
no teachers when I was born and I grew
up because I didn't have I could not go
to an amount you school because there
were no teachers who teach and so I had
to go to a unfortunately or fortunately
unfortunately when you are I had to go
to Dominican nuns in the morning that
was nuts and they tried desperately to
Christianize me in the afternoon my
parents said Peter daughter could tap
the Islamic say conventions of
schizophrenia here in the morning they
didn't think I'd be super-severe
emotionally and that's my whole day
there now will help you nuts but it's
that was that was life that
my life was very very tough particular
sorrow nigga cyrenaica bore the brunt of
this the Davidic line of population was
phenomenal the poverty they lack of lack
of infrastructure Benghazi back past the
biggest city in seronegative had homes
from shells for the linen buildings
until nineteen sixty-five it was it was
a horrendous a horrible horrible
horrible time in fact so much so that
really no country in the world wanted to
assume responsibility for Libya and the
only reason why the United Nations took
it is because of the bipolar issues
between the odd statement Soviet Union
that you find glasses or take it and
then and you know to do with it so they
won't make it independent and we all
give it will give independence and
meditative state and then we'll be into
a state true but did it have the basics
of being a state no honestly no and the
top of the log on aid from here aid from
the US selling it very ritory informal
basis rents and that's how it survived
its survival until discovery of oil in
1958 and once or discover it was
discovered you find a fundamental change
taking place but unfortunately the
change in LA so very long because the 58
into 69 not much some changes to take
place some infrastructure lyst was was
was done a little bit of release of the
pressure was was done but
not very much in nineteen-sixty-nine
when mr. Gaddafi came to power you would
think that he learned from the history
with this gentleman has been telling us
about but unfortunately that was not a
paladin raped on door didn't read any of
the theorists of graham shield here at
NASA NASA's vision for Egypt was really
quite different from that for Libya
proved to be the guiding path Philippian
development so if we look at the ribbon
economy miss Phinney that had passed
through number of phases but first of
all you have to understand that Libya
was endowed with anything except perhaps
a nice coastline one thousand seven
hundred kilometers of coastline
ninety-eight percent of the country's
desert
how big is the country the country is
about two and a half times the size of
Texas maybe they'll just bit larger than
Alaska and yet really much of the
country was desert of that I really if
you think about it proximately only 1%
1.03 percent of the total land mass is
arable
continuous production of food is on zero
point one nine percent of the land may I
think the total was in 4,700 square
kilometers or something like that this
is really arable land it is used but
much of the country is not and has
always and has always depended on
importation of food since becoming
independent now in Arabic the term is
Libya and it's funny when you write
Libya because you have rightly been
Arabic from right to left or from left
to right the same thing why is that it's
not a coincidence that when you really
think about that I mean it's not a
coincidence which I thought you said I
what I well mr. Chow and I made this
point you know if you were coming to
Egypt there's no reason for you to say
in Libya you stepped on weight with
Tunisia does the screen there's water
and if you're coming on Tunisia within
the state yeah you went along to Egypt
if you're in Libya that is something
that kept you there ok I think we poor
Libya's enjoy they do too much we enjoy
the destitute er we enjoy enjoy it the
way it is but we've never really had the
future and the peace of mind at least
those my agent on
that really deserve because we refer
them to this hint of dictatorship that
has there's no I can't find a proper
term to describe to you if I can just if
I can just in words and looking at my
notes over here I look at pre Gaddafi
error I refer to his bare survival it
was it was characterized by destitution
let later oil and a little bit of
progress the post-gaddafi era
the first of all saw a rapid progress
very rapid from nineteen sixty nine to
nineteen seventy-four we know if we're
not we saw a phenomenal change in living
lives little bit of little government
intervention a lot of development other
infrastructure development building
that came to nought prob stop 1974
and if your sink recy was involved and
that idiosyncrasy continued from 74 to
78 and I explained just experienced
briefly as I as I speak to you followed
by another period just following my
notes and I'll come back to it what I
call referred to from 78 2004 I call it
a period of economic suicide
and from 2004 on to today is a bit of
catching up now we understand
we look at Dubai Abu Dhabi and you see a
new Disneyland being formed the normal
developed to normal production
phenomenal growth
when Benghazi what we have Ben Ghazi
with Tripoli was a city beautiful city
with shops with infrastructure with
streets with the stadium's movie
theaters beautiful cognition on the sea
promenade sailing clubs dubai and abu
dhabi were two huts and a barn I promise
you that there were there were there was
50 years behind Libya in Libya was 50
years behind each and Kyle but still if
you compare today Abu Dhabi and Dubai is
a hundred years ahead of Libya
opportunity that was missed opportunity
when particularly after 73 when a flood
of oil in cash and money provided the
regime with a once their lifetime chance
to actually instigate and bring about a
fundamental change in the Libyan economy
that would be hard to shake but that was
not the purpose the purpose there after
that period of time was ideological
formulations if you like that took place
at the expense of the economy
today the regime says
it wants to catch up it was to institute
a market economy it wants to bring you
by the fundamental change
you know the way I see it in the way
I've studied it maybe i'm wrong but i
know a market economy requires three
things if you don't have them you can't
have a market economy the first of those
things that we require that economic
activity must in large part be conducted
by a private sector there's room for
state intervention no doubt about that
but in minimal role forces intervention
that's the first thing the second thing
to make a market economy happen is you
have to have respect for private
property should I have a staff of
private property wild and more into this
makes no sense and the third thing is
make it Abbott is respect for contracts
what I want to ask you is where does
Libya fit on these three 1974 a process
of nationalization of private property
began with article number four of the
law but the government decided that well
we'll take it over not yours that was
made much worse in 1978 and the second
stage began and the second stage began
by legalizing that public theft anyone
can go into someone else's property home
lat religious and take it over and
there's absolutely nothing you can do
about it nothing companies were taken
over by the state and the state says
well you really can't have a company you
no longer yeah yeah you have to have a
delicate monastiraki to share okiya
which basically means a to collect this
but it I guess it is well something like
a co-op they'll cover the rules for
co-op but it's not even a co-op okay
there's not the sort of co-op you own it
but you don't
you own your home but you don't I run
the state but I don't and we live in
this in this vacuum of of laws without
any doors I mean up there are no formal
laws that informal there are informers
but there are no formal ones and it's
very difficult to bring about any change
in this constant environment of
basically order this change you can't
you get you can't direct it in any way
and so I look and I see today the regime
wants to bring about fundamental change
in the economic structure of the society
okay we want to bring in companies to
build for us we want to bring do this
and do that I look and I see well new
the new Dubai Libya opens its doors for
business a California company has just
decided that it actually got it got a 80
billion dollar for building 100 1006
160,000 housing units for 80 billion
dollars
you know to me to me this is this is
this is exactly what rental economy is
all about the entire state is all about
we don't trust Libyans to build will
bring your company to make it for you
the elected open company you can go and
you do nothing the problem is very much
so today in Libya what you have
unemployment that is really really very
prevalent it would be up for the last 10
years I've seen unemployment to thirty
percent I don't believe that this is one
I don't believe any of the statistics
that actually come up from the state
because my experience and what I see is
that individuals are hard-pressed to
find love it they can't find work on the
cultural level of social level and it's
making even more difficult that and it's
really funny what is because we asked me
here well what measurements do you what
do you have I'll tell you what I use
something started struck me what struck
me a great deal was the fact that one of
a son I I witnessed an and I hear my
wife tells me and so forth but young
girls 20 21 years old girls marrying 40
and 50 50 year old men and I said what's
going on let's go when it once twice
three times what I understand but when
he is such hearing this going on and on
and on I asked what's going on so I
decided to follow it follow through and
see what's going on the truth is what's
happening is that young men and women
I'm not able to find a job so they kept
open a home they can't they cannot start
a life and women want to get married
because unfortunately in liberal society
this is the way it is you know and they
get married to older men as opposed to
men their own age because meta that they
tend to be better secure than younger
individuals who can hardly find jobs to
make ends meet and I looked at the pay
structure and the pay structure within
Libya this Mother's poor 200 Libyan
pounds 250 pounds that's what they get I
mean an individual's managers of
companies 200 pounds which is a
possibility of hundred dollars now the
exchange rate today is is one one dollar
for one pound for 1.25 wears it around
it's one it's one pound 1.25 took to the
dollar 1.25 to the dollar okay it was at
one time three pounds to the dollar not
anymore to just change dramatically and
so I see that what is really happening
is that opportunity for young people
to provide an work and and action excel
and be productive is declining is
declining and therefore many actually
leave government business to try to find
some jobs elsewhere but there that
becomes very difficult as well too so
soon where's it's gonna go what is this
headache
I don't know
the truth is I don't know what the
libman economy is going
idiosyncrasy
of the leadership is making very
difficult to move in any direction with
economy today they dominate it to a
large extent by a click a sport click
that is unwilling to experiment or
change or allow for the opening up of
the economy any direction many of those
actually have prison with the regime and
they're part of the regime and so you
have one strata and I was hoping they
would use about this you have one
structure on the top and that usually
made up by David revolution committees
because it's in their hands what goes
where how do what was responsible is
accountable they're not accountable but
this one strut and the other bottom
strata which is the people's committees
and they belong to mr. Chabot a modded
circle Parliament to be happy like that
that's pre aspire to move on that level
now yet the top totally it's totally
dominated by mr. Gaddafi himself and
close familiar allies the economy itself
is about three sectors today each one of
mr. Gaddafi's children is responsible
for one sector nothing can happen in
that sector without the approval of one
of the children
so I stood your question comes back in
what is going to happen what do you
expect to happen for another oligarchy
comparable to what we had not Russia I
don't know perhaps but when the economy
make the jump from what we see today
into a a a market economy I highly doubt
it because first of all the major
obstacle to that change itself is mr.
Gaddafi himself moving into a market
economy would provide centers of power
with influence and resources that he
would not be able to control and
therefore that's not going to happen
ultimately what you Remus understand as
Gaddafi and Libya's Gaddafi is a state
of dictatorship and see the
dictatorships some can be benign some be
malignant in this case
the truth is
Libya has past 40 years of malignancy
it's very very difficult is they default
to get out of that unless mr. that dirty
is willing to relinquish that hope
miss off your process thank you very
much it is remarkable the extent to
which the Libyan regime once one of the
world's most notorious pariahs has been
completely restored without a change in
regime something we will undoubtedly
water return to but first Titian please
stand whatever you like
I hope you don't mind me standing but I
i I'm not a very good I'm not very good
on chairs I just feel and also this sort
of you know a long table of the cloth
always I have almost kind of like a
phobia because they remind me of the
Revolutionary Committees and but of
course you know i am honored to be
sharing it with such a wonderful and
bright people i am a writer so I'm very
much out of this is not my you know I
the university is a place that I I feel
a stranger in so that so I'm a little
bit out of my depth but I am I am
indebted really to to all the organizers
and for the warm welcome the only other
thing I'm going to say is that I have
this cough so if I start coughing don't
worry
if I start wheezing don't panic if I
collapse give it five seconds before you
okay well firstly I would like to thank
Columbia University and in particular
the Middle East institutes for hosting
this event for their invitation and for
their generous and thoughtful
hospitality this conference was the
brain child abuse of acid has already
know of course an American student at
Columbia who has Libyan origins it was
his idea that we should all meet here
today and discuss within the liberal
walls of this university Libya he has
worked tirelessly over the past few
months to make it happen if we ever
needed cause for optimism about Libya
then surely the passion intelligence and
love of Justice of this distant Sun or
give us strength nine months ago Youssef
sent me a letter in which he articulated
how in the American University system
there is very little academic work
devoted to the study of Libya and now he
wanted to try and how he wanted to try
to go some way in rectifying this today
he has achieved an important step
towards this goal and for this I thank
him also in this regard like thank
assistant professor Bashir a woman for
his support of this project from right
from the beginning and pleased also and
frankly honored to be sharing the podium
with dr. Lisa Anderson of whom I've been
a big fan dr. Alameda who I haven't met
before and enjoyed having breakfast with
him this morning and look forward to
reading his work and dr. Mansour Akita
who I've sent I've only had sent about
three fan letters in my life and one of
them was two months old when I first
read his book was a wonderful encounter
and it's really great to be sharing this
event
I am going to speak about the Libyan
writer but I thought before I do that
just because I feel I mean I feel
slightly guilty for you know subjecting
you all to how awful Libya is a little
ring I feel miserable right now it's all
this legal stuff so yeah I don't have a
happy story to live it and what will get
there yes it'll be happy what I'm going
to say about the Libyan writer is in
kind of abstract sense the beat writer
is is not necessarily a happy story so I
thought perhaps i'll read something
short from my book in the country of man
that is i hope you'd find amusing so the
protagonist who is also the narrator of
the book is a an adult recalling this
particular summer when he was nine years
old and Tripoli and his name is sleyman
particularly in summer when the Sun
swelled with heat the whole world went
to sleep children adults even dogs found
a patch of shade to slumbering I never
learned how to now it always felt
strange to get into my pajamas of three
in the afternoon it reminded me of being
ill instead I would search the
neighboring building plots for things I
liked or thought useful things that used
to be knives or parts of old radios and
took them to our garden there I scraped
glue that was always losing out of the
joints of the blue tree got whatever
would I could find and carrying
everything in the rap of my arms I
climbed the straight flight of stairs up
to my up to the flat roof the roof tiles
were baking you could see the heat
rippling above them I had forgotten my
sandals so I hopped running for the
shadow made by the water tank to my
workshop I rubbed my feet on the
coolness of the shaded tiles I looked up
at the Sun I thought how strong the Sun
is how mighty and felt frightened by it
by the possibility of it not moving
or coming closer pressing down against
us like a giant balloon I remembered my
quran teacher sheikh mustafa story of
the bridge to Paradise the bridge that
crosses hell eternal to deliver the
faithful to paradise we all will have to
cross it someday and some of us won't
make it those will fall into the fires
below the fires that call for them what
a sight it will be the heat the
screaming there is bound to be screaming
the flames licking the sides of the
bridge making the handrails sheikh
mustafa said nothing about handrails but
there are bound to be handles hot to the
touch the heat will reach some of us
faster than others sheikh mustafa said
because for some the heat the fires of
hell themselves will be like a voice
calling i suppose it's like when you're
when you hear your name and you can't
help but turn to the source that's
spoken some of us will be longing for
hell eternal god forbid the way we long
to respond to obey when our name is
called even by someone we have never met
before or by a teacher who has asked a
question we know we can't answer we
raise our head and say yes and if he
can't see us we reach higher and shout
over here sir when we know there'll be
nothing to do except curler lipped and
shrug our shoulders because the fire
calls for the fire sheikh mustafa warned
me about this he said you must try to
ignore the heat Suleiman when you are on
the bridge to paradise you must keep
your eyes focused on paradise and the
beauty of paradise
and whatever you do don't look down
watching the heat ripple off the tiles
on the roof I thought I should rain I
should train myself for that day I
decided to walk not hot not run but walk
in a line as straight as an arrow
without even arching the soles of my
feet back to the staircase the staircase
was to be my paradise the first step
didn't feel as bad as I expected but
after a few steps the soles of my feet
were on fire and I found myself hopping
and running wondering if hopping and
running were allowed on the bridge to
paradise
my cough also means that I have to drink
hideous quantities of water you know
what that means
right so I'm going to try to say
something comprehensible about the
Libyan writer and as so much as one can
speak about such a complex figured such
a vague and fragile and nearly ephemeral
figure for Libyan literature has been
dealt so many blows that it now seems to
tremble at the edge of oblivion it is a
little literature that has for too long
been subjected to political interference
and an interference that has developed
so many ways to undermine the
imagination for if the Pater ship is to
exist it exists against the imagination
it cannot tolerate variance or
contemplation and therefore it cannot
tolerate spontaneity or dreaming
dictatorship is violently jealous and in
the words of the late resort kapuscinski
every dictatorship not only surrounds
itself with kitsch it is in itself a
vulgar political kitsch unhappy often
stained with blood it is the triumph of
kitsch not the harmless containable
kitsch of mass culture but an aggressive
kitsch which ruins the creative culture
poisons the social atmosphere and has
only hatred and contempt for the
individual but before I speak in such
direct terms I would like first to talk
about two events that took place in the
latter half of the 20th century that
although have nothing to do with Libya
say something I believe about the exist
n shal pool and thrust between politics
and literature in 1945 shortly after
liberation a charismatic french general
manages to convince an award-winning
french author to be his minister of
information approximately 45 years later
and an internationally acclaimed
Peruvian novelist puts his pen down to
run for office although wholly
unconnected these two events share
detail that is telling and curious in
its mirror likeness
General Charles the gold had been trying
for some time to convince the reluctant
Andre Malraux and man 11 years his
junior to take on the job of minister he
used the guilt argument your country
needs you he used flattery you're the
best man for the job and I'm sure the
goal also used the motley threatening
argument of so much would be lost if you
were to turn this down every tactic
failed it wasn't until all three were
employed with equal skill and fine
balance that the general succeeded that
night victorious the goal tiptoed into
his marital bedroom and woke up Yvonne
to go Yvonne turned on the lamp beside
her bed and squinted at the figure of
her husband unbuttoning his military
jacket I imagine the large brass buttons
eased out of the slits with more
willingness than usual he apologized for
waking her up where have you been she
said tonight he's older then perhaps
here he paused or perhaps he went on
straight on speaking the words quickly
tonight I assassinated under de malo
by this time ago I published la
condicin new man published in English
under the title man's fate a novel about
the exist n shal plight of a diverse
group of people after a failed
revolution he had also written blue
squad published in English under the
title man's hope about the Spanish Civil
War another historical drama that the
fated malvo had played a significant
role in fighting on the side of the
republican forces and indeed setting up
the legendary this squadron espana which
had inflicted serious losses on onto
Franco's nationalist army underway
beliveau ended up serving the goal until
the end of the generals presidency in
1969 first as minister of information
then as Minister of State and finally as
the First Minister of Cultural Affairs
in a different continent and about 20
years after mobo retired from public
life the 54 year-old Peruvian novelist
Mario Vargas Llosa already noted for
novels such as the time of the hero
conversation in the cathedral and the
war of the end of the world was running
for the Presidency of Peru late one
night he two walks into his marital
bedroom and silhouette it by the light
begins to unbutton his dinner jacket
waking his wife patricio so like Yvonne
baptisia too turned on the lamp beside
her bed and squinted toward her husband
but she did not ask where have you been
she knew he was in a political rally his
combed hair and his shoulders were
sprinkled with confetti no but Tricia
did not need to ask where Mario had been
all she said was once
and perhaps here too she paused once I
was married to a novelist many writers
distrusted user after his running for
office not only because in the
neoliberal nah not only because of the
neoliberal platform in which he ran
which many Latin American Asian African
and Arab intellectuals saw as betraying
the struggle for self-determination and
social justice it wasn't that I would
argue that turned their hearts they
distrusted him because they doubted his
commitment to literature they doubted
his faith and although and Rima was
political career is seen under a more
favorable light it to cost some readers
to shy away from his work for a time the
novelist must never be louder than his
work if he shouts he must chart and
prose if he is a whisperer then he must
do that too in art and keep silent
outside the page he must surrender his
goods and his ambition and his motives
and his causes and his hang-ups at the
door he must let literature set the
agenda and the challenges he must serve
her should he be foolish enough to
demand that literature serves him then
he risks the integrity of his work such
a novelist is like a man who embraces
his beloved was picturing another woman
every novelist makes these decisions
privately and sometimes without his
complete knowledge yet everything
depends on this question of fidelity to
art I remember when I was writing in the
country of men the novel set in Libya
and in which the constant and menacing
gaze of the dictatorship pierces its way
through the private quarters of a
family's daily life I often felt the
temptation to expose the awfulness the
sheer absurdity and vileness of the
Libyan dictatorship more
naked Lee a dictatorship that stole our
house a dictatorship that incarcerated
members of my family and several friends
a dictatorship that killed people i know
people i love people i admire so you can
see i had many reasons to make my book
an attack a catalog of their crimes i
had to resist this temptation and on the
other extreme when i was gripped with a
sense of panic fearing retribution
against me or worse members of my family
as indeed has happened to others who
spoke out in the past the temptation to
act as my own sensor in other words my
own oppressor was also great i tried to
resist that too if i succeeded in
protecting my work from such extra
literary concerns that I did it because
I was somehow convinced that to give in
to these temptations regardless of the
legitimacy of my grievances would turn a
work of fiction into a diatribe a dead
corpse for any writer caught amid such
tides literature must be his measure his
prose will show him up in the pros of
any work of literature one finds the
very DNA of the entire thing right there
in the sentences sometimes in the first
sentence a writer who thinks he can fool
language will be made a fool of by
language languages main purpose is to
betray us every word we utter betrays us
says a little more than what we think we
are saying reveals more than we have
anticipated exposes of exposes us
further and if I writers intention is to
use literature for his own ends then all
the evidence will be on the page
regardless how hard he tries to hide his
footsteps Yosa and malvo knew this
although at certain points in their
lives they felt it important that they
should devote themselves to public life
both were too good
and too honest to allow this to
contaminate their work this is their
virtue but also a possibility granted to
them by their environments they were
allowed to be both artists and citizens
to be selflessly committed to their
craft but also critically but also to
critically engage with the current
issues of their time in Colonel
Gaddafi's Libya this possibility is not
permitted the dictatorship sees
literature as a threat and therefore has
repeatedly treated writers as enemies of
the state actually just as a side as an
aside I think I might be I think I think
I might be correct in this observation
and all of our books are banned in Libya
I think I know you your books of it so
it's a you know this is just a yeah yeah
well I got great satisfaction on a
friend smuggled some in just fantastic
it's great in a sister you know the book
book returns the book is the book
Gillis's on somebody's you know on the
floor of someone's car something's
fantastic hopefully somewhere license in
that but the regime has persistently
attempted to acquire there will be an
author to possess him and ultimately to
possess language and the national
narrative this more than anything else I
believe has determined and limited
contemporary Libyan writing since
Gaddafi's coup in 1969 the fickle leader
had in the space of nine years changed
the colors of the national flag twice we
designed the national currency in order
to trick people into handing over their
cash and exhausted the goodwill of the
public that had originally welcomed this
new republican era the new regime now
penetrated every sphere of civic life it
implanted its agents the so-called
Revolutionary Committees so you see
allergy to revolution securities who
were obsessed with finding enemies in
every institution and organization every
club and union in the lecture halls and
the theaters corrupting the Society's
cultural vibrancy a vibrancy that burned
brightly in the 60s and even into the
70s they subjugated the press dismantled
one of the most progressive and
independent University student unions in
the post-colonial Arab world executed
its leaders in public squares and
imprisoning hundreds of its members
society was chased deeper indoors until
the only place Libyans could exist
unmonitored was inside their homes but
even that finally that but even that
final private domain was invaded by a
regular broadcast by regularly broadcast
interrogations of those the
Revolutionary Committees deemed
anti-revolutionary or traitors or
bourgeois or backward people who were
halting the march on national television
for their sit from their sitting rooms
Libyans watched men stiff with fear
under a camera's harsh lights answering
questions delivered by faceless voices
they watched summary executions in
football stadiums men hanging by the
neck swinging by a rope in the middle of
basketball courts and public squares
fear killed many poems fear killed many
novels fear was like Fornes in the mouth
writers had been imprisoned killed their
fingers sliced off the 1970s and 80s saw
the worst of these attacks but that
wasn't enough books to had to be
destroyed the army was ordered to pay a
visit to every bookshop and library in
Tripoli armed with a long list of titles
to be confiscated thousands of books
from Dostoevsky to Faulkner everybody
were set on fire in one of the public
squares all that remained
on the shelves of the start of
booksellers shops were educational or
revolutionary books and so began a
process familiar among dictatorships
everywhere the rewriting of history the
redefining of the present and the
singular vision of the future propaganda
films were aired showing the horror of
Italy's occupation followed immediately
by a victorious Qaddafi punching the air
with his fists as if World War two never
happened as if it was not Montgomery and
the British Eighth Army who defeated
Mussolini in North Africa and 1943 as if
King adrees never ruled Libya until 69
or had ever existed history rewritten
reality suspended perhaps dictatorship
perhaps the potato chips fear literature
because they see it as a competing
narrative the pitah ship is a sort of
hideous fiction in itself intolerant of
the very idea that there might exist
more than one possibility very idea of
other fictions the story of Libyan
literature is also an edible one not
edible but an audible Oedipus since the
difficult word notices that sound like
that it's not certainly not an edible it
is the story of fathers and sons the
story of sons against fathers and
fathers against sons for the dictator is
the distrustful jealous and controlling
father he breathes down the necks of his
children he examines every part of their
Anatomy he wants forever to live in
their skin the constant on their tongues
and for their eyes to be reminded always
of his image why else the endless
posters this is why this eternal
relationship with all of its
complexities and extremities is has
obsessed my fiction thus far
gaddafi's political and oedipal war on
literature has been effective but it can
never succeed by virtue of the fact that
literature is not a plant one can
approve but a vapor as agile as oxygen
it is by nature rebellious resists
control and will never be satisfied no
prizes no praise no success and no
torture or burning of books or closure
of universities could ever kill it it is
in everyone it is in every one of us
including those who have never read a
book those who do not know how to read
it's the clutter it's in the cluttering
tongues and the poetic ones it is wild
and searching and it finds opportunity
everywhere this is its genius and here I
would like to end with a small anecdote
concerning a Libyan blogger let us call
them X who was recently imprisoned and
tortured for his writing for two years
he pretended to be insane for two years
he spoke out loud to himself made up
stories characters wizards at times he
was the wizard or an old childless lady
or a lady with children I had left home
or an old man with a broken leg a man
who had lost his money and man who I
just found his money then another man
who believed he was a bird X was many
people during these two years but never
himself then finally when the prosecutor
arrived x ran in circles around him
asking would you like a Pepsi Cola
perhaps you would like a Pepsi Cola he
was released on the way home he stopped
at the first internet cafe and published
a list of all the critically ill
prisoners he knew of in prison just a
list not because anything would change
but because he could not bear the
insanity of silence
a year later when the authorities caught
on to the fact that X was never mad that
he was pretending they rehearsed Adem
and this time took him straight to the
mental asylum where he remained for a
year when I asked him how that year was
for him he said terrible then after a
long pause he added but I wasn't the
only one who wasn't insane he told me of
a Libyan ambassador who due to a
disagreement with Gaddafi had been
deemed insane and put in the insane
thing I asked him if he ever returned to
blogging or if the experience of torture
imprisonment in a year and a mental
asylum had not had not lost him the will
to record to write he laughed of course
I'm still blogging he said thank you
very much I think the
various of these talks have illustrated
the extent to which the 21st century was
a difficult one for Libya I don't think
there are that many countries where you
would have this variety of panelists
almost all of whom refer to hanging
corpses at various junctures in the
history of the country I was reminded
when Hashem observed that all of their
books are forbidden and I have no idea
whether mind is or not that when I was
doing was searched there there was a
room in the library of the University in
Benghazi that was the forbidden books
room and it's where they put them all
and the wonderful thing is that
foreigners like me could sashay into
that room because I didn't matter so all
of my colleagues would say so what's in
there what's in there so there is a
always a subverting of this forbidding
as I think if sham pointed out there's
never a real way to keep it completely
forbidden and I was struck as you work
including by the extent to which in some
respects your description of the Libyan
writer is not dissimilar from your
description of the popular poetry of the
colonial period this is a way of keeping
of being a witness of keeping a record
even in the content even in context in
which you aren't supposed to be able to
do that so at some point I think it
would be fun if we had an opportunity to
talk about the the uses of literature of
various kinds of literature and these
kinds of political circumstances that
said however I want to open the floor I
have lots and lots of things I think we
could talk about but if in if any of you
have comments to each other I'll
was that and open to the audience itself